okay we got guys guys let's
let's practice innocent until proven
guilty because
i will not stand for random accusations
just because he beat me which is
which would be ridiculous let's check
the game
with a computer and then we can make
some judgments all right i don't want to
i don't want to hear
bs because we haven't analyzed anything
yet i don't care what he is
but imagine if you were 1300 and you
actually did play the game of your life
would you like somebody to just
with one throw of the hand say that
you're cheating because i certainly
wouldn't
so let's check it with the stockfish
[Music]
all right so five minute games and let
us get started hope everyone is ready
we have been experimenting with the
accelerated dragon
sicilian
okay we're white against richard let's
go e4
okay so he plays the modern which we've
seen quite a bit recently and the
purpose
the modern basically contains its
essence in its name it's an opening that
really came into business quite recently
and and as i mentioned in my youtube
video
yesterday like 150 years ago people
would laugh at this
because you're giving white control of
the center uh but the reason this is a
hyper modern opening is because
in the 1920s a group of people came
around and they said wait a second let's
let our opponents control the center
and then we're going to attack this
center from a distance king's indian
modern all those are part of
sort of the hyper modern openings now he
goes c5 that's a move
that is a move and we're going to take
the spawn now sometimes black tries to
take this knight and he triples our
pawns
but in return for tripling our pawns he
gives away a very important bishop thank
you both of you for the sub
so queen a5 attacks the pawn and attacks
the knight twice
which one of the two should we defend we
should definitely defend the night i
don't want to let him fork my king and
my rook that's
that's not good so let's just defend
this and that you know simultaneously
we're developing a piece
in the meantime he's using his queen a
bunch and and capturing pawn so
this is already a very dubious line now
we're going to centralize our knight
with knight t5
and we're aiming potentially for this c7
square uh this is actually i think the
best way to punish this line this is
theory
uh although i haven't brushed up on it
in a while there's a lot of tactics that
will happen
uh and and if you're watching this you
should already be looking for ways to
get the queen onto a square where you
can for oh
this guy has nerves of steel bishop
takes b2
now we can move the rook away and that's
entirely possible and let's move the
rook away there's no reason not to let's
get rid of this threat first and then
we'll think about ways
to harass the queen now what is the
purpose
of our play what are we trying to
accomplish well our ideal scenario
is to get the queen onto a square such
that knight c7 is gonna fork the queen
the secondary scenario is to get the
queen on a square where it doesn't
control c7 then we win a rook
so bishop b4 comes to mind as a way of
chasing the queen away from its control
over the c7 score but after queen c6
there is a crucial move that we have to
find in order to dislodge that queen and
priority number one comes into play
when we do that um priority number one
comes into play when we do that
uh because if we already are primed to
look for ways to get the queen onto a
forkable square then we of course see
the move bishop b5 that's very easy
but you have to know what you're looking
for and people don't do enough of that
you have to set your priorities and set
your
objective of your calculator what are
you trying to find in the first place
that way you're not just grasping at
straws okay he realizes that he's in
trouble he can go queen d4
then we'll just take the queen and win
the rook he has no other choice he
either gives up
his rook or he gives up his queen a
great choice
queen d4 is technically best because
after bishop b5 his queen is trapped you
can go to e6 and then we fork him
anyway
thank you unclear well this is what i
live for
and i'm not done yet i might go until my
flight in the morning
okay um so
he's thinking he realizes it and that is
why i and i always say this but
i don't recommend beginners to play
these kinds of openings because
it's it's and my my russian professor
made this analogy about learning russian
it's like driving a bus
okay you're learning how to drive and
you're like man
you know i want a kind of car that helps
people who learn how to drive
uh and let me get a nice bus i'm gonna
learn how to drive a bus before i learn
before i know how to drive a car
uh now is driving a bus impossible
absolutely not it can actually be
pretty powerful if you know how to do it
if you don't know how to do it it's a
hot mess
back home to san francisco
uh and i don't know if this analogy is a
little too far out but i think it helps
people understand why these kinds of
openings
can be good at gm level but hard to play
at a beginner level
or same can be said with manual
transmission
worst invention in the world okay uh
bishop
he resigns and it done for unfreezes
brief f sorry it briefly oh what if he
plays bishop c3 and we just take it
we take it because our knight defense e3
and now we win the rook two
we win everything uh so again
remember to count the number of
defenders and attackers that's all there
is to it right
one two and basically he only has one
uh y4 y4 hd that's what we like to see
thank you
now was bishop takes b2 a good move
bishop b2 was terrible
i don't actually know what black is
supposed to do here but at the very
least
the very least trying to at least you
know
you know draw you at least you know what
does kasparov do i think knight a6 maybe
to control the c7 square
although i can't take the knight but now
at least i don't have a light squad
bishop so c4 is not off limits anymore
but how do i know that bishop takes b2
is bad how do i know that so quickly
the reason i know that it's not magic
it's intuition
i can just sense that because he hasn't
developed any pieces and i have this
tactical idea in play
he's going around grabbing pawns and
moving the same piece again and again
chess is not a magi well it is a magical
game but it's also a logical game
and when you violate this many
principles you're bound to be punished
nine times out of ten
you know there are openings there are
exceptions with modern computers came
openings where you violate a bunch of
principles and you get away with it
but those are rare like the poison pond
and the night orf and you have to know
them extremely well
any questions about this game
any questions about this game
i don't play subs during the speedrun i
play random people in the pool
okay why did you decide to move the
knight instead of developing other
pieces well
the reason i decided to move the knight
first of all i'm already ahead in
development so i can get away with this
second of all i see that the c7 square
is very weak for him and i can stick a
knight there and deliver a fork
that is number one number two i see that
a queen
is in the vicinity of that square so not
only can i deliver this
check and win the rook but potentially
i'm already seeing tactics where i lure
the queen onto a forkable square this is
too juicy not to play but
i mean if you play knight f3 that's fine
white is still slightly better
no problem it's just that knight c5 is a
little bit more ambitious
so i'm pretty old okay 15 minute games
cesar is what i would say
okay um what if he pushes upon to get
your knight away well
if he pushes the pawn to get my knight
away let me call up the game
then you don't have to move the knife
and
this is one of the biggest weaknesses
that beginners have is the knee-jerk
reaction
he attacks the knight let's move the
knight we got him with the knight no
we don't because there's a queen we can
set an equal or stronger threat we can
still go bishop before
attacking the queen queen moves up to c6
what is y2 can somebody remind me it's
the same idea that we had in the game
bishop b5 notice that we have not moved
our knight
okay because the queen is tangled up
that's why you don't bring your queen
out in the opening because you can
can be easily attacked knight c7 and you
win the queen
okay next game that was relatively
simple
mr mr pink okay
so let's play the king's indian for the
first time i've played the queen's
gambit thus far
let's play king's indian which is my
opening the opening i have played for
basically all of the time i've played
chess probably since the time i was 1700
i used to play the queen's gambit
now what is the purpose in one sentence
of the king's indian king's indian
is a hyper modern opening right it
really came to being in the 1920s
when people realized that controlling
the center with pawns isn't everything
so black makes a modest claim to the
center but if fiance's bishop which is
good
night is developed naturally you castle
quickly all those things are great
and in terms of controlling the center
what you do is you prepare this move e5
because e5 is a very weighty uh way to
control the sound how do we prepare e5
what's the best way to prepare e5 in a
manner
conducive to our development there's two
main ways to do that in the king's
indian
rookie 8 is not the best way to do it
because remember the key principle guys
do not
assign a task to one piece if you can
assign it to a piece of lesser value
so let's just play knight c6 and prepare
e5 this way that is a
principle that really does hold up a lot
of the time if you can assign a task
to a piece of lesser value do not assign
it to the rook or queen
because the rooker queen should be
reserved only for the very important
tasks such as winning a lot of material
now the movie four does not work
because he takes we take he takes but
this is exactly the kind of position
where we would assign the queen a task
and the queen could be used to prepare
the movie for he has has to play e4
himself and that kind of blunts the
bishop now look at his pieces they're
all staring at this pawn
where's she knight bd7 is also good
where should we put this bishop
where should we put this bishop
and that's a very natural move although
usually the bishop is not developed here
in the king's indian
but what would be the point of rookie 8
then the rook and the queen are just
biting on granite yeah let's go bishop
g4 active development
yeah bishop on d3 creates fork problems
he has to go back good job on by him to
go back let's bring a rook into the game
everything i'm doing so far supernatural
just bringing pieces into the game
now we have to decide whether we trade
bishops or not
and i personally don't see a reason to
trade the bishop but where should we
drop this bishop back
should we go back all the way to c8
i don't know why we would exchange here
i mean let's go to e6 let's just go back
i don't think there's a big difference i
think both moves are fine
and now i'm going to display one of the
key ideas of the king's indian one of
the key ideas of the king's indian is
the preparation of the f5 pawn break
that is the reason why so many people
like the king's indian and the way to do
that
is to remove the knight from f6 notice
that i'm not just putting the knight
anywhere i'm putting the knight on a
square where later
it can make its way to f4 let's chase
the bishop away
if it goes to h4 okay it goes to e3
and now we can accomplish the main idea
of the king's indian which is the move
f5
beginning the king side operation we got
nemo with a rape party at 390. thank you
to you thank you nemo for the
for the big raid you came at a great
time because we are doing my speed on my
instructional speed run we are in the
middle of a game thank you so much
black to play here we need to preserve
the bishop we need to preserve the
bishop because if we allow him to take
it
he's going to put his bishop on c4 and
this is where i want to share something
very important
do not be afraid of retreating moves
people have this pathological fear
of making a retreating move and you
absolutely shouldn't fear that he's
playing extremely well now he takes f5
as a great move
let's take bishop takes f5 and he's
gonna probably fork us with queen b3 but
the good thing about our position is
this queen is kind of bogged down on b7
this gives us a very important
opportunity to make stuff happen on the
king's side
how can we make stuff happen on the king
side particularly since the knight is
hanging
well this is where we have a tactical
idea that tactical idea
involves intercepting the bishop's
defense of the knight on g5 what move am
i thinking about
yeah this guy is uh this guy is playing
very well
but we'll see what do we do how do we
intercept
the bishop's control over the night we
need to call jimmy garoppolo here he'll
definitely find an
interception all right
we take on f4 we're attacking the knight
he's attacking our knight
the pawn on f4 is very strong can later
push to f3
shattering the defenses around white's
king we are down a pawn
but what do we have in return for the
spawn we have a big attack against this
king
we have a pin against the pawn on g2
what tactic does this immediately call
to mind
what tactic does this immediately call
to mind
it's a football reference bishop takes
h3
he cannot take the bishop because he's
pinned we also create a pressure point
on g2
okay take stakes bishop f3 would be very
strong here
okay do we trade we are attacking
so we shouldn't trade let's go back to
f8 in addition the rook and fe what is
it doing here
it might seem to you that it's simply
biting on granite but the reality is
we have the possibility at some point of
playing the move f3
what do we do in such a position we have
several pieces that are not doing
anything in particular the bishop on g7
where can it go
where can this bishop go in order to be
somewhat employed
not f3 because he takes with the bishop
in the interest of time i'm gonna play
fast this guy's super strong
so we need to play a little bit fast
let's go bishop e5
okay knight t4
now let's open stuff up with f3
let's open stuff up with f3
now very good player
we need to drop this bishop back the
reason we need to drop this bishop back
is to pave the way for the queen to make
its way to h2
he's does our bidding for us now let's
go queen h4
let's prepare to infiltrate via h1
he's he's very very strong i mean he's
extremely underrated and he's actually
outplaying me right now so i'm actually
focused
you guys will have to let me focus for a
second
i did not anticipate this from my
opponent he started very badly now he's
playing extremely well oh
no this guy is uh this guy's beating us
i'm sorry to say guys
after a very poor opening
yeah okay this is uh this is very
interesting
we will check this game but um yeah this
this guy this guy got the better of me
here in this in this key
key battle in the game no not a smurf
definitely not a smurf but outplayed me
in the worst position is pretty
impressive
c5 yep let's take three seconds on a
force move
queen d4 and rook g5 perfect play
okay we will check let's let me reserve
my judgment although you guys can read
my lips
and let's take three seconds on a mating
move between f6
okay we will we will check the game
i don't usually lose to 1300s but there
are exceptions
okay pretty impressive 1300 ladies and
gentlemen
oh my lance so he plays a bad opening
knight a3
i mean bishop d2 but this is actually
computer let's see
let me do this properly and check
stockfish on my chest space
okay wait wait wait guys guys let's
let's practice
innocent until proven guilty because i
will not stand for
random accusations just because he beat
me which is which would be ridiculous
let's check the game with a computer and
then we can make some judgments all
right i don't wanna i don't wanna hear
bs because we haven't analyzed anything
yet
i do wanna give people the benefit of
the doubt
okay i don't care what he is but
imagine if you were 1300 and you
actually did play the game of your life
would you like somebody to just
with one throw of the hand say that
you're cheating because i certainly
wouldn't
so let's check it with the stock fish
okay
now i'm what i'm gonna do
is i'm going to include stockfish one
second
so we're gonna skip the first couple of
moves
because black is much better e4 here was
strong
okay so we're gonna start here okay e4
was top
we're gonna do the top two moves bishop
e2 was the top move
so anyways um basically starting from
this point look
castle's a stop top top top
top okay he made one in accuracy which
is knight g5
but after that track takes takes top top
brook 81 a second top top and that king
f1 is a crazy
king f1 i actually found this resource
f3 bishop ca which is strong
king f1 is the top move which is
incredibly suspicious just to run like
this
straight under bishop a6 knight e6 is
also good
top means first first choice of stock
fish now even knight c7 just grabbing a
pawn
and seeing that you could run back queen
c6 two
queen a6 queen a4 queen 84
we found queen a4 rogue d5 also
okay i mean he really made it obvious at
the end very obvious at the end
um because
yeah queen a4 is what makes it obvious
because of all the moves you could play
here up a piece he chooses
a random queen move
i know man this is crazy but we will
they will investigate and make the
appropriate conclusions
i knew this was going to happen at some
point just because
this kind of stuff happens but let's not
get too worked up about it
let's not get too worked up about it i
will report him
and chess.com has an unmatched algorithm
and they will give her the benefit of
the doubt
if indeed he played honestly sorry i
can't beat stockfish that is not among
my talents
okay so we're gonna play another king's
indian hopefully this one works a little
bit better
so my opponent is again playing a very
weird opening
and uh again in the king's indian
the purpose is to prepare this movie fi
and um
another way of doing it is actually to
put the knight on d7
um one second
thank you mr hoopkiss for the sub now
the funny thing is
and this is a typical king's indian
tactic we can play e5
we can play e5 uh and
he could have taken the pawn and i will
show after the game why black doesn't
lose a pawn
so let me write this down now do we want
to open the center with e takes d4 who
can tell me
why or why not we should open the center
using the kind of logic that we have
discussed at several points on the
speedrun
so we should because his king is in the
center very good uh
tarik his king is in the center our king
is not
that is a crucial observation which
basically tells us that if we open up
the center we can
perhaps better exploit the fact that his
king is still in the center now how
should we exploit it exactly well
fact of the matter is the pawn on e4 is
pinned which means it cannot move which
means that what move comes to mind in
order to try to win that pawn
d5 is correct good job yale work and if
he castles he gets forked
okay he goes e5 good move but now the
spawn is very weak
how do we go about winning the spawn 100
bits thank you thank you
how do we go about winning this pawn
where should we put this knight now by
the way the knight is not being attacked
we are not moving the knight because
he's attacking that we are moving the
knight because we want to win the pun
very important so there's no confusion
now we're going to win a very important
central pawn
yes he's going to get to castle he did a
good job not you know not panicking
but he's going to be down a very crucial
central pawn our bishop is going to be
super
strong and he's in very big trouble
so in any case yeah i take c5
and we're going to remove knight takes
c5 we don't want to now generally this
king's indian bishop
we do not you do not generally want to
give away a fiance bishop that's that's
a good rule for some of you guys to
learn
the fiance bishop is very important
because if you give it up
you create a ton of holes along uh the
moves that you kind of board out with
the move
g6 so you would only give the fiance
bishop away for a lot of material and
even then sometimes you don't
what should we do here how this bishop
is annoying me now knight takes f3 does
not win a piece
knight takes f3 does not win a piece
because he takes with the knight
and that knight simultaneously defends
the bishop 24. so how do we try to get
this bishop onto a square
where it can be captured by this bishop
let's go c5 and chase the bishop maybe
he moves it back
and then he blunders a bishop what
should he do he should play knight takes
e5 or bishop takes c5 but that gives
away a crucial bishop in his own right
and then our bishop on g7 is going to be
uncontested which is exactly what we
want
okay very good knight takes e5 our
bishop is now uncontested
and incredibly strong along the long
diagonal we're up upon
we have a great position out of the
opening and he plays a weird move rookie
too
now let's take his other bishop so that
we have two bishops against two knights
in an open board
awesome stuff where should this bishop
go
think about exactly what this bishop
should be doing what should it be
attacking
where should it go i know a lot of
people are probably going to say g4
right now
but it's a lot more effective for the
bishop to come to f5 i talked about this
two days ago i think on the speedrun
where rather than doing something
general like delivering a pin
you want your pieces to be doing
specific things here the bishop is
attacking a weak pawn
and that weak pawn is very hard to
defend because he's so passive
we're gonna take on e1 if he takes to
the queen we take the pawn if he takes
with a knight well then he has to bring
another piece back
all right thank you for the pawn now
what do we do in this position to win
we're up two puns a lot of people
struggle to win positions like these
there is a checklist of items that you
can go through the first of these items
is whether or not we can create a
passpond
when we are up bonds by definition it
should be easier for us to create past
funds can we create one
particularly because bishops are a lot
better than knights at managing past
pawns
we have a pass spawn on the d file but
we can create a better one on the c file
why
because if you look at the bishops and
what they're doing specifically what
squares are they controlling
boom boom they are controlling c3 and c2
both squares that the pawn wants to go
to so the red carpet
for the pawn has been unraveled if we
tried to push our deep on it would have
been much harder to push it further
uh in part because the bishop is in its
way
c3 c2 comes with tempo and then we can
use this bishop
to control the promotion square and
promote winning a lot of pieces
very simple the knights are dominated
knights are very bad at stopping past
pawns remember that principle
now a lot of people would play c2 here
but could somebody tell me why c2 might
be a little bit inaccurate what does it
allow white to do
uh which may prolong the game for a
couple of moves
red fury you deserve a sub for that very
good
he might take on c2 now yes we're open
exchange i don't want to give this pawn
up just for an exchange i want to win
this queen so what should we do
we should go rook c8 very patient move
bring the pieces
into the game 91
he's defending well he wants to take our
bishop i don't particularly care about
that
and actually we can make a very tactical
move here let me make the move first
and then i will explain it afterward i
can play c2 i know you guys are whoa
whoa whoa see we're blundering the pawn
you're allowing him to take a bit what
are you doing
i will explain it there is a tactical
reason behind the smoke
the tactical reason behind this move is
that first of all if he takes my bishop
then i take back
okay so in this position there's
multiple ways to win the game
uh can somebody name one of them
and i would recommend that you think
about this by trying to understand
where the queen on dc on d8 belongs
yes zazy gifting to redfear thank you we
should take the knight
and what move should we make now to end
the game immediately bishop h6 very nice
you guys bishop h6 wins the game on the
spot i actually didn't even see that
the other move would be queen d1 same
idea dislodging the queen from
c1 guess what we did we gived up the we
gived up we gave up the theme keto
bishop
and we gave it up for very good reason
we gave it up in order to make a second
queen that is a worthwhile cause
to give up our king's indian bishop it
gives itself up for the greater good
he correctly gives this queen up for the
rook and for the pawn but it doesn't
matter
we're going to combine the queen and the
rook to win this knight combine the
queen and the bishop rather to win this
night and
that game is going to be over kinetic
energy our pieces are full of kinetic
energy
here and kinetic energy is exactly what
we need
and we win the game now the move c2
uh when he resigns which i'm
anticipating because we are about to win
his knight as well
it is gg okay how do we win this
position well the easiest is to go after
this pawn and then promote our password
we don't even need to go after that pawn
we could
straight away make a pass pawn uh by the
way
i would not recommend people pre-move in
such a situation because he does have a
knight
i also see a lot of people in such a
situation giving up their queen
for the last remaining piece there's no
need to do that you don't need to like
eliminate all of your opponent's pieces
he's only got a knight that's not a big
deal here i can pre-move v2 because he
was pinned
he's probably to go here i have a
feeling he's going to go there
no knight f4 mate very good now let's
jump right into the move c2 why did i
make this move
the move knight takes c2 seems to refute
this because if i take and
the number of defenders equal the number
of attackers and so
this is just a trade and we lose our
promoted fund so can somebody tell me
what it
is that i had in mind here i want a
couple people to think about this
to tell me what the move is in this
position
as i open another lock
that moves indeed queen c7 and the move
queen c7 wins the pin tonight on c2
because he cannot bring the other knight
to reinforce it
and so i will simply win a full piece
and i also have a pawn and the rook is
arrested or trapped because the bishop
is completely circumscribing it
that's the king's indian bishop for you
ladies and gentlemen
how did i find this move how do i think
of a move like c2 like what is the
process
and i know a lot of people are wondering
like great i see the point
now tell me how the hell you found this
move first of all be under no illusions
it is not the only move in this position
we could have also dropped the bishop
back and attacked the rook and then
attacked the rook again
and in this position what could we do to
get a screen out of c1 that would be the
alternative way to win this position
and then i will explain the process
behind finding such a move
circumscribing not circumcising it's not
bishop h6 because the pawn isn't on c2
yet
here we have to play queen d1 we
basically force the queen out of c1 it
can go to f4 or whatever but then we go
c2
and in this case we go c2 again
now in order to help you guys understand
how to find such a move
i will refer to my good friend sam
shanklin i call this the sam shanklin
question sam shanklin question is named
in his honor
good friend of mine he's grand master
former u.s champion from the bay area
i've known him for many many years the
sam shanklin question
it's not that he invented this but when
he teaches at camps he always has a
lecture on this topic
and i think it's a very inspirational
topic and the topic is when your
opponent prevents a threat
when you have an idea and your opponent
prevents that idea or you feel like it's
impossible
the question you have to ask yourself is
what happens if i do it anyway
you have to ask yourself what happens if
i do it anyway because that alerts it
awakens in your brain it basically
passes the membrane
which tells your brain i can't do
something because that square is
defended because that piece is hanging
because this is threatened and it allows
you to consider moves that you otherwise
wouldn't consider
and this is a great example of that your
brain tells you that this is impossible
because this blunders a pawn but if you
stare at this position for a second most
of you stop queen sisab
it's a it's a weird kind of paradox but
it actually really works and i can give
you many examples of when i applied this
success that's not the only way to find
c2 but that is one thing that you can do
to lighten your tactical load sorry that
wasn't the actual position
um the actual position was this one
although it doesn't matter so knight e1
prevents c2
that's the purpose of knight one what
happens if we do it anyway ah i have
queen c7 winning the night
i hope this makes sense to you guys i
can give you plenty of examples but i
want to keep the speed run rolling
i can let me actually look up my games
for a good example
oh i can give you an example against sam
shankland
uh one of the few games in which i've
beaten him
he is a much stronger player than me and
he has speed me many times so
be under no illusions that but i have a
good
good example of a game against sam many
many years ago where i actually applied
this principle i didn't know it exactly
by name
but i i did uh sorry something is wrong
with my
stream
sorry my stream is going crazy
i don't want this
okay there we go finally i get to be a
speedrun live my pleasure
one moment please ladies and gentlemen
this is a very this is one of my
favorite yeah 10 bucks from bill bill
thank you so much
bill bill with a bomb i really
appreciate all of these donations all of
the bits all of the subs
that's really awesome and again i
this this means so much to me so thank
you everybody
okay
so i'm just again chess space is very
finicky when it comes to obs
you guys will have to be a little bit
patient thank you eric for
500 bits let's go
this is too much guys thank you so much
eric
and finally i am ready to show you guys
to see this is a great great example
it's worth the wait
this is one of my one of my proud
moments jam jam with a thousand bits
uh-oh we're going in in increments of
500 now
all right
so
finally we can switch to the chess-based
scene neritsky against shankland no
these ratings are not mistaken i was
1900 sam was 2100.
yes that did exist we are playing in
2006
and we reached the position that is in
front of you
now in this position i found a really
really strong idea
and i found this idea by applying a very
similar logic
uh to the sam shanklin question slightly
different but i'll explain
now how do we look at a position like
this material is equal
and it doesn't seem like very much is
going on there is no peace and balances
both sides have a knight in a bishop
black has some pressure going on on the
queen side right he's got he's got some
some ideas down the a file maybe
but white has i have my own assets i
have a very nice blockading bishop in
the center
and i have some action here potentially
with uh
with some f5 pawn breaks so
basically i was thinking about going g4
and f5 but it is a little bit weakening
so i decided not to do it but then i
i thought i i basically made a wish list
and and
this is something i recommend to people
uh very strongly to make a what does the
wish list mean it means
you look at your pieces and you say you
know if i could put a particular piece
on
any square i wanted what square would
that be because that can again awaken in
you
the sort of tactical instinct so this
knight i wasn't happy with it's on c5
it's got a lot of kinetic energy but
very low potential in it what is it
doing like it's not really doing
anything just sitting there
you cannot take the pawn because that
pawn is defended and i thought where
would i want to put this and where where
do i really want to put this knight
there is a very juicy square somewhere
in black's territory
that i can potentially get this knight
to
well i want to get ooh i want to get
here and why do i want to get it
i'm going to make why the hell
do i want to get here well because this
is a beautiful knight and if he takes it
lobster pins are made coming up one
order this is amazing for the attack
black doesn't have his fiance bishop he
talked about this
but i can't get the knight to uh to f6
because both squares
are covered respectively by the pawn of
the queen
and then i ask myself the sam sam
shanklin question rather than abandoning
the idea
you ask yourself what happens if i do it
anyway and which move did i play
which move did i play in the game
it's not knight d7 i'll give you that
hint that does blunder the knight
and a lot of you have already said the
move it is 94. very good
94 is correct because if d takes e4
then that pawn was defending the other
night i take the other knight
and white is much better here i don't
get to get the knight to f6
but look at what happens look at how
many weak pawns he has now this pawn is
oh
i want to highlight it sorry this spawn
is weak and this spawn is weak
now his bishop is terrible so this is a
horrible scenario
and if he doesn't take then he's got to
allow the knight to f6
and so this basically won me the game
sam did
have a resource here that would have
preserved a
solid position for him which is the
desperado sack knight 65 i believe
but he missed it and actually uh the
funny thing is i didn't even immediately
get the knight to f6 i first
sorry he went h6 i went h4
and h5 and then i got the knight to f6
he took it
and i basically well i didn't made him
but the attack
was incredibly strong i'm actually
threatening now to take on h6 with
checkmate and this is all because he
doesn't have that bishop and this is all
because of this pawn and he finally gave
his rook up for it
but i got a winning end game i won't
analyze this in depth
but you guys get the point the sam
shanklin question ladies and gentlemen
very very important in order to find
creative tactics
does the bishop have to take my knight
well if he doesn't take uh that was the
lesser evil relatively speaking
uh because if he doesn't take then i'm
basically gonna lift my rook up and i'm
gonna have some queen sack ideas
um in any case there's many games where
i can show this but let's go back to the
speedrun
and let's continue with the next game